Yeah, good morning and welcome to this program on Hands-on Approach to Artificial Intelligence
for Real World Applications.
So, in today's one hour lecture, I am going to introduce what is artificial intelligence.
The details of this techniques will be covered in subsequent lectures by other teachers.
So, just to introduce what is artificial intelligence before that let us see how our natural intelligence
actually works.
So, I start with these two pictures.
The question is do you recognize these pictures?
Now, whether you recognize or not that is not that important, what is important is how
do you recognize?
Obviously, I believe that you know the picture on the left is cave painting from Ajanta
caves and picture on the right is our parliament building, old parliament building I will say
in New Delhi.
Now, how do you recognize?
Naturally, you must have seen these pictures in your history book during your school days
or maybe somebody has shown you these pictures a number of times, possibly some of you have
visited these places, gone to the Ajanta caves and seen these paintings yourselves.
So, when you look or when you see such pictures, what you do is you create a description of
these pictures some form of description.
Why I am saying some form of description is that even if the same objects or same pictures
are shown to you in a distorted fashion, in the sense right now the pictures which are
shown are in color, so if instead of color just black and white version of the same pictures
are shown to you or the pictures are slightly distorted, it is scaled up, scaled down, rotated
even then you will be able to understand.
So, that clearly says that what you have understood is not the picture itself or point by point
content of the picture, but some description you have made of this picture and these picture
these descriptions are stored in your brain in some form of a model.
So, next time when similar such pictures are shown to you, you try to extract similar such
descriptions and then try to associate those new pictures to one of the pictures which
are stored in your brain based on some sort of similarity or dissimilarity.
So, that is how our natural intelligence works and naturally when you understand something
or when you form a model this model does not is not formed in a single instance.
Say for example, in your school days when you have started learning the alphabets A,
B, C, D and all, so your parents or your school teachers must have told you A for apple, B
for ball and that has been told a number of times, it is not only once and after hearing
that after looking at those characters a number of times you have been able to remember it
or you have been able to create a model of that which has been stored in the brain.
So, when you talk about machine learning or artificial intelligence, you find that at
the input we have the signal which are the raw signal, this signal can be an image, this
signal can be some time domain signal something like a speech and all that.
So, when I talk about image, it is the visual recognition that comes into picture and when
it is a time domain signal like some music or speech, it is our auditory system that
comes into picture.
So, we should be able to recognize whether you are watching a dog, whether you are watching
a bird, what type of bird it is.
Similarly, when it comes to your auditory signal or speech, you should be able to recognize
whether you are listening to say Hemant Kumar or you are listening to Latha Mangaskar and
you can easily identify that.
So, how does it actually work?
So, given an input signal, the first thing as I said that we create a description, some
sort of description.
Similarly, come to coming to machine learning for given signals, we try to find out some
sort of features, not a single one, multiple number of features from those signals and those
features are put in the form of a feature vector.
So, every feature vector represents a particular signal.
Now, how this feature vectors are important?
The moment you convert or you translate a signal from the raw domain say for example,
from image to a vector, the moment I put it in the form of a vector, my recognition task
becomes very easy.
Let us say for example, we have a vector of say three-dimensional, you just extract three
different properties or three different features from the given signal and you have a three-dimensional
feature vector.
Now, once I have this three-dimensional feature vector, then this feature vector represents
a point in our three-dimensional space.
So, if I have two different signals or if I have two instances of the same signal, it
is quite likely that the feature vectors corresponding to those two different signals will be very
similar or they will be very close in the three-dimensional feature space whereas, if
I take two signals which are very wide say for example, I have a picture of a bird and
I have another picture which is the picture of a car.
So, again those two three-dimensional feature vectors that you create one out of bird and
one out of car, these two feature vectors will be very different and in my three-dimensional
feature space, the distance between these two points will be very large.
So, I can just find out whether two signals are similar or they are dissimilar depending
upon what is the distance between the corresponding feature vectors.
So, once I have this feature vectors, then I can put, I can fit those feature vectors
into a classifier or the classifier will classify other or recognize the signal to be whether
it is a bird, whether it is a car, whether it is a dog and all that.
So, I can have different types of classifiers, some are Bayesian classifiers, SVM, neural
network and all that.
Out of that I will put more emphasis on neural network because all your subsequent lectures
are mostly going to be based on neural network approach.
So, let us see when I say descriptors, what are different types of descriptors we have.
So, here I have shown few images, you find that on the top I have the silhouette or just
the boundary of two different animals and you can easily recognize that the left one
is the boundary of a horse and the right one is the boundary of a zebra.
However, given only this boundary information, if I want to compute what is the difference
between these two boundaries, the difference is very very small or they are very very similar.
So, maybe based on just this, I will come to a bit later that how from these boundaries
we can extract different information which can be useful for differentiating between
these two animals or different types of animals.
But as I said, as I was saying that based on just this boundary information, it is very
difficult to differentiate between a horse and a zebra.
So, in addition to boundary information, so with this boundary information it is quite
possible that I will be able to differentiate between a horse or a zebra that is a class
of horse and zebra and class of birds, but differentiation between a horse and zebra
becomes very very difficult.
So, in addition to this boundary information, we need some more information and you remember
that in case of a zebra, if you look at the body of a zebra, mostly you have black and
white stripes whereas in case of horse, you do not have black and white stripes.
So, along with the boundary information you use some more information which is the region
information and these two informations put together gives you a feature vector which
can be used for differentiation between a horse and a zebra.
Now, when you come to the region property or the region descriptors, we can have intensity
profile as has been shown on the image on the right hand side, you can have color as shown
on the left bottom image or you can also have texture as shown in the right bottom image.
So, these are different types of informations that can be extracted from the same image and
when you talk about this informations, obviously as we are talking about feature vector, so
these informations are to be quantified or I should able to compute some new numerical
values representing these region properties.
So, I will come to that a bit later, let us see what how this boundary descriptor can
be generated.
So, you find that I have given a closed curved boundary and what I can do is, I can find
out or I can represent this boundary by a polygon.
There are different algorithms, how you can get a polygonal approximation of a curved
boundary I am not going into that, but for the time being let us take it for granted
that given a curved boundary I can have a polygon.
So, what I have is a polygon something like this.
Once I have such a polygon for every such polygon, obviously I have a number of internal
angles, so let us put this internal angles as alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3, alpha 4 and
so on.
Now, these angles can be scanned either in the clockwise direction or in anticlockwise
direction I can use any of them, but I have to keep in mind that if I use clockwise convention
I always have to use clockwise rotation.
If I use anticlockwise I always have to use anticlockwise, so if you scan these images
either in clockwise or in anticlockwise fashion, then you have you find that I have a sequence
of internal angles say alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3 and for 4 and so on.
These internal angles of the sequence now I can take this as a time series, so there
is no time involved in it, but it is a sequence of some angle values.
In this sequence I can have an autoregressive model over this sequence.
So, in this autoregressive model what I do is I give an any angle alpha i, ith angle
I can represent this as a linear combination of p number of previous angles, so the expression
comes something like this.
So, alpha i is equal to beta k alpha i minus k where k varies from 1 to p, so this is a
pth order autoregression model.
So, you find that there are p number of coefficients beta k which are autoregression coefficients
and I will get if there are say n number of internal angles or if the number of vertices
of the polygon are n, I will have n number of such equations.
And you solve all these equations simultaneously and you get the values of your coefficients
beta 1 to beta p and these coefficients this set of coefficients will be different for
different types of polygons.
So, I can represent or I can use these coefficients as some sort of description or approximate
description of the given boundary shape, this is one set of features that I can have.
Another set of features that I can have is you see that when I represented this as a
polygon I have missed a number of detailed information, so if I want to include some
such detailed information in the description I generate, then I can follow it something
like this say given another boundary close boundary suppose I have a polygonal description
like this.
Out of this if I take just this particular segment on the left side, so segment is over
here, now the kind of processing that I can do over this segment is I represented this
you just rotate this by an angle, so that the linear segments becomes horizontal and
the curved boundary that particular segment now is a function of the distance on the linear
segment which was the linear approximation of this curve boundary.
And if I normalize this particular segment in the sense the area between the curved segment
and the horizontal axis I make it equal to 1, so that is the kind of normalization that
I perform.
So if the area between the curved segment and the horizontal axis becomes 1 then I can
consider this to be a probability density function.
So what I get is PR versus R that is the probability of occurrence of R, once I represent this
as a probability distribution function then I can compute different statistical moments.
So you find that the statistical moment of order 2 this is very very familiar it is nothing
but what is called variance.
I can have other form of statistical variance statistical moment also, so statistical moment
of order 3 which is called skewness, statistical moment of order 4 which is called kurtosis
and all that, out of this the third order statistical moment which is skewness it is
very easy to understand what it gives it gives whether your distribution is skewed towards
left or skewed towards right, similarly each of these statistical moments give you some
information of shape of the boundary.
So what I can do is earlier we have got the auto regression coefficients and I can concatenate
with the set of auto regression coefficients all these statistical moment values.
So I get a larger feature vector.
So this is the set of feature vector that you can get simply from the boundary information.
Now what are the different types of region descriptors I can have?
You find again on the left I have shown the black and white image for that I can have intensity
histogram I believe all of you know what is the intensity histogram and this intensity
histogram if I normalize that is sum of contents of all the histogram means is equal to 1 then
this normalized intensity histogram can be considered as a frequency of occurrence of
different intensity values that means what is the probability of occurrence of different
intensity value within this image.
So again it becomes a probability density function.
So once it is a probability density function again I can compute a different types of statistical
moments which gives you information of what is the shape of the histogram of that black
and white image.
Similarly if I want to find out the color distribution or color properties you know
color image consists of three different planes the red, green and blue plane.
For each of the planes I can compute similar such histograms for each of the histograms
you can compute the statistical moments all these things taken together gives you some
information of how the intensity profile of the images, how the color profile of the images.
The same thing comes when it comes to this texture again from the texture I can compute
a different types of properties one of them is what is called a co-occurrence matrix.
The co-occurrence matrix is given two intensity values i and j and some positional constant
say distance in this particular case I have shown a 45 degree ij that means if I take
two pixels two points p and q which are at a distance of one and oriented in the direction
of 45 degree then if the intensity of pixel p is i let us let us say 10 and intensity
at pixel say 15 then I want to find out that how many times these two intensity values
10 and 15 following this positional constant 145 degree occurs within that particular texture
and that I do for every pair of intensity values.
So you find that for a particular positional constant say 145 degree I get one matrix which
is called a co-occurrence matrix that how many times 10 and 15 these two intensities
following this particular constant occurred within this given image.
So this is for one constant positional constant I can compute this for multiple positional
constant.
So this co-occurrence matrix in that case will be different for different types of textures
and once I have this co-occurrence matrix if I normalize this co-occurrence matrix that
is some of all the elements of in the matrix I want to make it equal to one then it becomes
a joint probability distribution function and the moment it becomes a joint probability
distribution function again I compute all these I can compute all these different values
which gives you some information of what is the texture that I have and these values will
be texture dependent.
So you find that we have computed descriptors based on the boundary and we have computed
descriptors based on the intensity profile we have computed descriptors based on the
color profile we have computed descriptors based on the texture.
All these different quantities that we have computed if we concatenate them one after
another then what we get is a feature vector and these feature vectors are likely to be
different for different objects because different objects will have different shapes they will
have different colors they will have different intensity profile they will have different
color profile.
So once I have these vectors as I said that in my feature space if I have this hundreds
such vectors hundreds such components feature components then I define a feature space of
dimension 100 and each of these vectors becomes a single point in that hundred dimensional
feature space.
So given two such vectors if the distance between these two vectors these two points
is small I can put them in the same category if it is high then they will be in different
categories that is basically how your machine learning works.
These are other types of regional descriptors that we can compute one is based on weblet
transformation I can compute the descriptor based on another very very popular filter
which is called Gabor filter now I spent some time over here because you find that these
are two templates which are shown over here as two small images just below the bigger
image that we have right.
If I convolve this given image with the template on the left then an output image that I get
which is on the bottom left similarly if I convolve the same given image with the template
on the right that is the smaller image your output will be what you get on the bottom
right.
So you find that information content of the output image on the left and the information
content on the output image on the right they are different and they will also be different
if your input images are different I can compute some property from these output images may
be simply the energy content of these images the energy content is nothing but sum of squares
of all the pixels within these images.
So given different images the energy contents of the outputs will be different not only
that if the templates that I use the templates are different then the energy content of the
corresponding output even if my input image is same that will also be different.
So if I have large number of such templates convolve your input signal or input image
with all those different templates and the output image that you get from different templates
you compute the energy content of the output images put all those energies in a particular
order that also becomes a feature vector right and why I said that I am going to spend more
time on this is I am talking about convolution.
So this convolution operation helps you to find out the feature vectors which are descriptors
of your input signal most of the part of this particular program will be on deep learning
and deep neural network and the basis of the deep neural network is the convolution operation
the basic neural network which is used is the convolution neural network.
So this is the convolution operation and in those cases the convolution kernel which in
this particular case I am saying these are Gabor kernels and for Gabor kernels like the
mathematical expression is also given G is equal to exponential of minus half x prime
square by sigma x square plus y prime square by sigma y square cosine omega x prime this
is a fixed form of a Gabor filter.
Now for different signals I may need different types of such kernels which will give you
the appropriate type of information.
So in case of convolutional neural network which is the basis of deep learning these
convolution kernels are actually learnt they are not fixed.
So the parameters of the convolution kernel will be learnt using the learning mechanism
which is the back propagation learning or gradient descent procedure I will touch upon
that briefly.
So this is what I said that given any input signal I represent those signals by feature
vectors and the feature vectors are nothing but different points in the feature space.
Let me assume that I am finding out say two dimensional feature vectors that means I just
compute two different features whatever it is I mean just for the ease of putting them
in a two dimensional plane.
So if I have a bird for the bird maybe I will get a 2D feature vector the features are x
1 and x 2 that will be placed somewhere over here.
You take another bird because the two birds are not identical so it is quite natural that
the feature vectors will not be identical but they will be very similar.
So the feature vector of the second bird will be somewhere near the previous feature vector
that we had.
The third bird will also be somewhere over here but if I have a car the same 2D feature
vector for the car is likely to be very different from the feature vectors of birds.
So they will be put a bit away from the previous set of feature vectors.
Similarly another car which will be near to car if I have a dog the feature vector will
be placed somewhere over here.
So if I continue you find that feature vectors for different classes of objects they form
clusters for the same class.
So here I have feature vectors corresponding to the birds here I have feature vectors corresponding
to cars that is again a cluster here they are feature vectors corresponding to dogs
it also again forms a cluster.
So effectively what I have is a distribution of the feature vectors and this distribution
is object dependent or category dependent.
So in terms of artificial intelligence we call them class conditional probability density.
Now once I have these different clusters my recognition task becomes very simple what
I can find out is what are the boundaries among these clusters.
So given these 3 different clusters I can have 2 boundaries as shown over here hopefully
I mean if you are fortunate enough these boundaries will be linear but the boundaries are not
linear always that depends upon I mean whether it will be a linear boundary or non-linear
boundary that depends upon the nature of the probability distribution function that you
have.
So once I have these 2 boundaries you find that these 2 boundaries divide the feature
space into 3 different sub regions.
One of the sub region is A, one of the sub region is B another sub region is C. So this
is what is learning what you have learned is based on the feature vectors which are known
and their class I can find out class conditional probability density function this is for the
known classes for the known samples.
Once I have this class conditional probability density function then I find out the boundaries
between pairs of classes.
Once I have these boundaries basically using these boundaries you are dividing the feature
space into a number of sub regions.
Now if an unknown feature vector is given to you I just find out whether that unknown
feature vector belongs to class A region A or unknown feature vector falls in region
B or it falls in region C. So if the unknown feature vector falls in region B my immediate
interpretation will be that particular object or that particular signal or image is the
image of a car.
If the unknown feature vector falls in region A my immediate interpretation is that particular
image is the image of a bird.
So this is how your classification works.
So firstly we have to get the feature vectors get large number of feature vectors of known
classes using those large number of feature vectors we are training the classifiers and
when we train the classifiers basically we find out the different sub regions within
the feature space.
So this is what I mean graphically if I want to put those class conditional feature vectors
class conditional probability density functions this is how it will look like we call it p
of x given omega i where x is the feature vector and omega i is the ith class this may
be class of birds it may be class of cars and so on.
But the simple base classification rule is so there what I had is p of x given omega i
along with that we have another probability which is p of omega i that is what is the
probability that given in a particular environment or in a particular problem domain what is
the likelihood of the occurrence of a particular class that is what is p omega i.
What I am saying this is suppose your environment is a forest in the forest it is quite likely
that you will have wild animals and it is unlikely that you will have a car but even
having a car is not impossible because we have enthusiastic tourists who may enter the
jungle with a car right but the probability of finding a car is much less than probability
of finding a wild animal.
So if my classes are say omega 1 which is class of wild animal and omega 2 which is the class
of car then p of omega 1 that is apriori probability of a wild animal will be much more than the
apriori probability of a car so that is what this p of omega i means what is the apriori
probability.
X is the unknown feature vector so I want to find out given an unknown feature vector
to which classes belong so I have to compute what is p of omega i given x and the base
dual this is basic probability theory that gives this.
So if I have now c number of classes for every such class I find out what is the p of omega
i given x for i varying from 1 to c and for whichever class for whichever value of i this
p of omega i j given x is maximum I classify my input vector x to that corresponding class.
So classification rule is very simple this if p of omega i given x is greater than p
of omega j given x for all j not equal to i then our decision is in favor of class omega
i that is what our base classification rule is further adjust mathematical details and
skipping it for the time being for the sake of time.
So as I said that we have different types of classifiers just now what I said is a base
classifier we can also have support vector machine so what this support vector machine
does in our earlier diagram over here when we have shown this class boundaries.
So I have a boundary between every pair of classes what should be the position of this
boundary the support vector machine because depending upon the position of the boundary
the error in your classification will depend if the position of the boundary is not at
appropriate place then error in classification will be more.
So support vector machine is a tool which tries to find out the best possible position
of these interclass boundaries so that the error in your classification is minimized.
Similarly we can also have a type of classifier which is called linear machine we have neural
network we have deep neural network.
So as I said that most of your subsequent lectures will be on neural network and deep
neural network so you will have details of this neural network and deep neural network
lectures.
I will just brief give a brief on what is neural network and what is deep neural network.
The neural network is actually motivated by our concept of our brain works though now
people have started realizing that what we believed when this neural network was introduced
our belief on how our human brain works it is not may not be similar.
But anyway so a neural network consists of a number of basic elements which are neurons.
To the neurons the neuron gets input as the feature vector a feature vector as the input
makes linear combinations of different components of the feature vector.
So for that I have an white vector.
So it computes the dot product between your feature vector and the weight vector that
is W transpose X and then performs a non-linear function F over this W transpose X to give
you the output of a neuron.
These neurons can be used to compute various types of functions and combinations of neurons
or a network of neurons can be used as classifiers.
So the non-linear function one of the non-linear function that is that can be used is a threshold
function which is given over here that F of X if X is greater than or equal to 0 the output
will be 1 if X is less than 0 the output will be 0.
This is one type of non-linear that can non-linearity that can be used as an activation function
of a neuron.
Similarly the other kind of non-linearity is a sigmoidal function which is given by this.
So you find that the difference between the threshold function and that the logistic regression
of sigmoidal function is that the threshold function change was abrupt.
But in case of the sigmoidal function the change from 0 to 1 that is continuous it is
not abrupt.
So as a result the threshold function is not differentiable whereas the sigmoidal function
is differentiable and you will do it later in subsequent lectures when details of neural
network will be told that this continuous function output function non-linear function
is very very important because the way the neural networks are trained that uses the concept
of differential calculus.
So differentiability of these non-linear functions are very very important.
So for neural network the non-linearity which is used is one of the non-linearity is this
sigmoidal function there are other kind of non-linearity also that will be told in your
subsequent lectures.
So for example this Rayleigh or rectified linear unit is one of the non-linear functions
which is used widely used in deep neural network there are reasons for it instead of using
sigmoidal function they use Rayleigh non-linear.
So a neural network is basically an combination or an interconnect of different neurons.
So given this interconnect of different neurons these neurons are arranged in a number of
layers and every layer we have a number of neurons.
So effectively you have a typical neural network will appear something like this where you
have different layers of neurons and in every layer you have different numbers of neurons.
So let us see that just to give an introduction that how these what these neurons can do.
So first of all I will take a single neuron and if I take a logical function say and function
and all of you know that and function works like this that ending of two input components
binary components if both the inputs are X 1 and X 2 and my output is Y then if both
the inputs are 0 output is 0 if any of the input is 0 output is also 0 if both the inputs
are 1 output is 1.
So I can consider this function as a classification function as a classification job and function
as a classification job that if both the input components of the feature vector 1 I will
put that input into one class correspondingly the output will be 1 if any of the inputs
or both of the inputs are 0s then output is 0 and I put it in another class.
So you find that for 0 0 or 0 1 or 1 0 these are the outputs and for 1 1 the output is
this ok.
So these are two different classes one is represented by 0 the other one is represented
by 1.
Now my boundary can be a straight line whose equation is X 1 plus X 2 minus 1.5 is equal
to 0 there can be a large number of boundary equations which will satisfy which will work
for this classification problem.
But I just take one of them that is X 1 plus X 2 minus 1.5 equal to 0.
So here if I put any of X 1 or X 2 or both of them to be 0 you find that your output
will be negative put the threshold function output will be 0 only when both are 1s then
output is 0.5 which is greater than 0 so put the threshold output will be 1.
So your classification task is satisfied.
How can I use a neural network for doing this task?
My neuron is this this one is bias I have 2 inputs X 1 X 2 and I have a bias term 1.
So my input vector becomes 1 X 1 X 2 weights I put as minus 1.5 1 1 so your linear combination
of the inputs is obviously becomes X 1 plus X 2 minus 1.5.
Now we put the threshold so if this linear combination is greater than 0 it will be 0.5
if both X 1 and X 2 are 1 then output will be 1 if any of the inputs is 0 or both of
them is 0 then output will be 0 so my classification is satisfied.
Similarly you can also verify I am just keeping some slides for the sake of time if the feature
vectors again I use 1 X 1 X 2 as my input vector now I change the weight vector like
earlier it was minus 1.5 now I make it minus 0.5 the other 2 are 1 1 remains as it is so
here you find that only when both X 1 X 2 are 0 output will be 0 if any of X 1 X 2 or
both of them are 1s output will be 1 after the nonlinear function.
So simply this implements an OR function.
So a neural network can implement an OR function single neuron can implement an OR function
and AND function.
Let us come to another function which is XOR function in case of XOR function you find
that I cannot classify or generate design a classifier using a single neuron because
there is not a single boundary there are 2 boundaries.
So I can break this XOR function in this manner you all know this I am not going to into detail
so you find that I have hierarchy of functions OR function, NAND function and AND function.
So this first 2 can be implemented using 2 neurons and in the second level in neuron
I will have final AND function.
So my neural network now consists of 3 neurons which are interconnected like this the first
one computes X 1 plus X 2 X 1 or X 2 the second one is X 1 NANDed with X 2 which is X 1 complement
or X 2 complement and the third one is the ending of these 2 that will be my final XOR
output.
So that is if I have a nonlinear boundary between classes then I cannot use a single neuron
to have the classification but I have to have multiple layers of neurons to represent that
boundary.
So a neural network typically or multi-layer neural network will be typically something
like this each of these are different layers of neurons.
So from every layer you feed the data to the next layer and so on.
So a function that you are computing is embedded function where F k is the function of F k
minus 1 something which is again function of F k minus 2 something and at the first level
or the bottom most level I have F 1 X.
So I have F 2 of F 1 X, F 3 of F 2 of F 1 X and so on.
So these are basically embedding of different functions finally, combinedly that gives you
a nonlinear function and nonlinear function which is very very powerful for performing
the classification tasks.
So this is what I said this is a typically multi-layer neural network and the way you
train this network what I said is back propagation learning how do you train?
As I said that initially for training you give a number of samples for which the classes
are known.
So I know the target output for those samples but given a new sample my actual output I
get is O it is not target output.
So I have an error which is O minus OT.
So back propagation learning the way it tends the network is so you find that I put theta
as the set of parameters where parameters are the interconnection weights.
So your output is a function of interconnection weights depending given your input X.
So the way you try to minimize this error is you try to tune this interconnection weights
W ij in such a manner that your error that is O minus OT is minimized and for doing that
what you do is a gradient descent approach the mathematical expression for that is given
at the bottom.
So if you take the derivative I said that differential calculus is very very important
for training of the neural network and this is where you use the differentiation.
So you take the derivative of error with respect to the set of parameters and based on the
gradient of this based on this derivative you try to update the parameters theta until
the error is minimized that is how a neural network is trained.
Now all this that I said are handcrafted features right we said that we will have intensity profile
we will have this color profile and all that we will have boundary descriptors these are
called handcrafted features because we the users tell that what kind of features that
we are looking for.
Now let us take an example that how do you recognize the Taj Mahal.
So all of you know that it is a Taj Mahal.
But if I say that you are wrong will you agree I show you the next slide this is the one
that I have shown you before and this is the one which is actually Taj Mahal.
So you find that these two monuments are very very similar.
So based on the handcrafted features that we have talked about earlier using those possibly
we cannot differentiate between these two monuments.
So that is where the handcrafted features fell.
So here what we need is the machine crafted features.
So instead of telling what kind of feature we want you leave this job to the machine
to decide that what kind of features the machine wants or machine will use or extract to differentiate
between these two kind of the different types of objects.
So for that you can have another kind of neural network which is called this is a network
which is a three layer network where the number of input nodes and the number of output nodes
they are same and in between what I have is a bottle neck layer.
This is a kind of network which is called an autoencoder.
What I want is whatever signal you give to the input I want the same signal to be reconstructed
at the output.
So I compute what is the error between the given signal X and the reconstructed signal
X hat.
While the information flows from the input to output it passes through this bottle neck
layer where the number of neurons is much less than the number of neurons in the signal
and your output side which is the decoder side is able to reconstruct the signal using
whatever is available whatever is fed from the middle layer.
That means in the middle layer you are capturing some description of the input signal but at
a much lower dimension which is sufficient for the decoder or the output layer to reconstruct
the same signal.
So after this network is properly trained what I get at the middle layer is a descriptor
a low dimensional descriptor or feature vector of the input signal.
So once this network is properly trained this autoencoder is properly trained I can remove
the output layer because I do not want reconstruction I want the descriptor of the feature vector
which is available from the middle layer and these descriptors can now be given for used
for the classification purpose.
So this is my autoencoder model if you analyze these are the different types of features
which this autoencoder actually encodes I am not going to that details and as I said
that after training you remove this decoder layer or the output layer that is what is
that is not required I need output from the bottle neck layer as the feature vectors and
use these feature vectors for training the classifier and for subsequently classifying
the different objects.
So the traditional machine learning where we had handcrafted features that can be avoided
and use this machine crafted features that the machine itself uses.
Now I will come to this convolution neural network as I said that convolution is a very
very important step in modern machine learning or deep learning techniques.
So here I give just two different templates I am not going into what these templates are
that will be clear.
So if you convolve say on the left I have an input image convolve these images with
just these first kernel you will get image on the middle convolve the same image with
the right kernel you will get image on the right.
So if you just analyze these two images what is there on the middle and what is there on
the right you find that the in the middle image you have extracted horizontal edges on
the right image you have extracted vertical edges.
If I superimpose these two I will get all the edges of the given image and these edges
will definitely be different for different types of images two different images will
not have same set of images.
So this convolution helps you to find out the descriptors or features of a given image
and that is the basis of your convolution neural network.
So here when I said that these are my kernels I have two 3 by 3 kernels.
So instead of specifying this kernels as minus 1, minus 2, minus 1, 0, 0, 0, 1, 2, 1 and
all that I put this kernels as variables this kernel elements are variables say A, B, C,
D, E, F, G, H and all that.
And while training the neural network or deep neural network I want to tune the values of
these kernel coefficients.
So my entire training will be something like this I will again I mean short is of time
so this is how the convolution actually works yeah I will come to this.
So you have input image I have the final classifier output the rightmost block.
These are the convolution layers in the convolution layers you have a number of kernels it need
not be one kernel only I can have a multiple number of kernels and depending upon the number
of kernels that you have you have the dimensions in the future vectors.
If the number of kernels is 5 you compute 5 dimensional feature vector if the number
of kernels is say 100 you compute 100 dimensional feature vector every convolution kernel gives
you one feature.
Initially these kernels are not fixed the kernels have different kernel coefficients
which are variables and by back propagation learning you set what the proper kernel coefficients
will be.
So in a typical CNN architecture or a deep neural network architecture this is the architecture
we have you have a convolution layer then there is nonlinearity as we said then we have
a pooling layer pooling layer reduces the dimensionality of the feature maps that you
have.
So this is a stack of computation units or one unit within a CNN architecture or deep
neural network architecture.
You have repetitions or stacks of these units and depending upon what is the size of the
stack whether I will have 5 such units, 10 such units, 100 such units that is what defines
tells you what is the depth of the network and when you say deep neural network the term
deep actually means depth that is how many layers of these units convolution layer nonlinearity
layer and pooling layer we have.
And you find that before classifier before this class I have a fully connected layer
this fully connected layer is nothing but the multi layer neural network that we talked
earlier.
So before this fully connected layer the purpose of using convolution nonlinearity and pooling
is that you extract the feature vectors or features from the given image and once this
features are extracted these features are given to the fully connected layer for classification
purpose.
Taining in this case earlier we said that you give the feature vectors and you compute what
is the output find out what is the error between the output and the target output and you minimize
your parameters theta using the back propagation algorithm or gradient descent algorithm such
that you can minimize the error.
Here again say if I give an input image which is the image of a bird at the classifier output
I have a number of nodes one node for every class.
So if I give an input the image of a bird I want that my target output will be that
the output node corresponding to bird will be 1 all other output nodes will be 0 that
is what is my target if I get anything else that is my error.
So I compute what is the error between the target and actual output that you get and
then through back propagation through gradient descent you modify the weight vectors as well
as modify the coefficients within the kernel in such a way that your error at the output
will be minimized and that you do for all the classes.
So finally at the end when your network is trained now you give an input image the network
is likely to give you the corresponding output image.
So this is how your CNN architecture or deep neural network architecture works.
I will just skip all these I will come to one particular topic that is the neural network
of the model that we have told so far we have talked only about understanding what a given
object is or given images whether an input image is a bird or the input image is a dog
it is a car and all that that means we are discriminating among different objects or
different classes.
So this is the model which is called the discriminative model Richard Feynman I hope all of you have
heard his name the great physicist he once said that what I cannot create I do not understand.
So till now what we have said that is that we have understood what the input object is
but that was superficial because until and unless I am able to create the same object
based on what I have understood I did not really understand it.
So that means we have to have another kind of model which is called a generative model.
So for a generative model again you train the model with a large number of the input
data and once the model is trained properly I want that given some brief description of
the object I should be able to generate that object.
So this brief description is nothing but the future vector.
So what I mean by that is suppose I give a description suppose these are the features
how big is the animal how many legs it has so these are different features.
So if I simply say that I have a big animal which has 4 legs it has big ears long trunk
a pair of tasks and all that with the help of this my generative model should be able
to generate what this object is.
I believe you have been able to guess which animal I am talking about it is nothing but
an elephant right.
So we are actually generative models because given this short of description crisp description
I have been able to say that it is nothing but an animal a generative model is expected
to work in similar manner.
Give the feature vector the generative model should be able to give you the image or give
the feature vectors the generative model should be able to generate speech.
Of course there is risk involved in generative models it can lead to many of the problems.
So this is what the feature vectors or the latent vectors that we have because of lack
of time I cannot go further.
So all these that we have talked about today they will be discussed in details in subsequent
lectures.
I believe there are lectures on generative models as well yeah okay thank you.
What is the bias in neuron see bias term is given an input vector say if I talk about
two dimensional vectors okay x1 and x2.
But even in two dimension you find that if I have boundary which is a linear boundary
the equation of the linear boundary will be of the form ax1 plus bx2 plus c equal to 0.
So if I say that a, b and c they are the parameters which define the linear boundary and x1 and
x2 are the features.
I have three parameters and two features I said that I want to have a linear combination
of the input vector with those parameters.
So that I can generate the output right mathematically instead of saying that I have two features
in my two dimensional feature vector if I introduce just one more term that is 1.
So I make my feature vector as 1 I think I can use this.
So I had two features x1, x2 and I had a boundary of this form.
The boundary had a equation ax1 plus bx2 plus c is equal to 0 right.
Here my weight vector w is equal to cab this is my weight vector and my feature vector
is x1, x2.
So instead of x1, x2 if I write it as 1, x1, x2 then you find that I can put this expression
as w transpose x is equal to 0.
So just by appending a third element in my feature vector 1 my mathematical expression
becomes very simple right and I can treat this w as a vector or as a parameter which
can be tuned by back propagation.
So that is how we are introducing a term which is bias term.
So if the same is coming as a neuron in the neuron I will have c, a and b at the output
I will have af of w transpose x.
This is what the bias term does ok.
You can act a white board here also white key curve or here white again.
Where are these Bayes' rules required and applicable?
When I talked about Bayes' rules I said let me write it P of omega i given x is equal
to P of x given omega i into P of omega i upon P of x ok.
Let me just forget about P of x because P of x will come in every such term.
So that can be ignored.
So effectively P of omega i given x becomes P of x given omega i into P of omega i.
As I said P of omega i is the a priori probability of a particular class occurrence of a particular
class how frequently you are going to encounter that particular class.
This is the feature vector for every feature vector and where this is required while training
your classifier.
You take a large number of samples say for example class barred.
I take a large number of images of barred.
I take a large number of images of dog.
Because these are the two classes that I have.
From the samples of barred you compute feature vectors x let me call it x barred.
From the samples of dog you compute the feature vectors let me call it x dog ok.
But from the feature vectors until and unless it is stored from which class the feature
vector has been computed you do not know right given only the feature vectors I do not know
from which class whether the feature vector is from a barred or a dog.
So for training the way the feature vectors are given is it are given as pair x barred.
That is I know that these feature vectors are computed from the samples of barred.
This is used for training similarly for all the feature vectors which are taken from the
class dog these are given in the form x given dog right.
So given this large number of feature vectors x now you compute what is the distribution
of the switcher vectors.
So if I assume that this distribution in most double cases we assume that given large number
of feature vectors usually it follows the Gaussian distribution of the normal distribution.
So for the normal distribution I will have a vector mu and a covariance matrix sigma.
So for all the samples which are taken from class dog I will have a mean mu which is mu
of dog and the covariance matrix sigma which is also computed from the same samples which
are taken from dog.
So this are the parameters of my distribution.
Similarly coming to the barreds I will have mu for barreds I will have the covariance
matrix sigma for barreds.
So when I say this P of x given omega i this P of x given omega i is computed from this
known feature vectors.
So here for barred I will have P of x given omega b which is the class barred and this
will have a distribution say normal distribution having mean mu barred and the covariance matrix
sigma barred.
That is the distribution of the feature vectors corresponding to this.
Similarly for the distribution corresponding to dogs instead of mu b and sigma b it will
be mu d sigma d.
So that is the normal distribution of having parameters mu d and sigma d.
So first when I compute this a posteriori probability I compute P of barred given x
which is equal to P of x given barred into a posteriori probability P of barred.
And this P of x given barred has to be computed from this distribution for this feature vector
x.
Similarly I will compute P of d given x that is dog given x.
So out of these two whichever is more if P of b given x is more than P of d given x then
this unknown feature vector x will be classified to barred or it will be classified to dog
if it is otherwise.
So this a priori probabilities or the class conditional probability density function is
to be computed beforehand using the known samples and this distribution that you compute
using that distribution you have to compute P of x given omega i for unknown x.
Now how to clear this let me write how this probability distribution will look like just
a mathematical expression P of x given let me write say barred it will be 1 upon 2 pi
to the power d by 2 we are talking about barred right.
So my sigma will be sigma barred to the power half and then I will have an exponential term
exponential minus half into x minus mu b transpose sigma b inverse x minus mu b that is the expression
for class conditional probability density.
So this is the class conditional probability density for class barred.
So you find that in the expression I have the covariance matrix corresponding to the
feature vectors of barred and also the mean of the vectors of the class barred.
So this covariance matrix sigma b and mu b these are the two parameters which has to
be computed using the known vectors and after these known vectors from these known vectors
you get these two parameters.
Now I have the analytical expression of the conditional probability density function.
So now for any unknown feature vector x I want to compute P of x given omega i where
now the omega i is barred that unknown x has to be fed here these two are the unknown feature
vectors.
So using those unknown feature vector values here I have to compute what is P of x given
b for the corresponding x ok.
So that is where your class conditional probability density comes into picture this helps in taking
the decision or computation of a posteriori probability value.
And for whichever class the posteriori probability value is maximum we classify that unknown
feature vector x to that corresponding class ok.
What are the different types of learning tasks a i can perform ok.
Given today's chat GPT or even this deep seek I do not think there is any domain where
a i cannot perform the task a i can perform or learn almost everything right.
So when we talk about what a i can learn mostly the kind of thing that I have discussed is
based on images that is the visual signal a i can learn the audio signals ok.
Say for example I can use artificial intelligence I mean something which is easily conceivable
I can use the same a i model for monitoring a power plant how.
Say in case of a power plant there are different machines every machine is a dynamic machine
it is creating vibration ok and that vibration is nothing but a time domain signal.
When you drive a car you find that when you are driving you get some noise that noise
is because of the vibration which is created by engine it is also the acoustic vibration
which is created because of friction between the car wheel and the road.
Just yesterday I was coming back from Calcutta the driver stopped in between and said sir
I get some peculiar sound from the wheel possibly there is some problem.
So you find that he had recognized that there might be some problem based on some abnormality
that he observed from the sound.
So we can train an a i model to find out or to detect any sort of abnormality in any kind
of environment and the moment you get such a kind of abnormality you get an warning you
get an alarm and you can take the particular action.
I was taking example of a power plant there also the vibration sound the sound of vibration
that has a particular pattern.
If anything goes wrong anywhere the vibration pattern will be different.
Now it is not possible for a human being always to manually here physically here the vibration
pattern and detect if there is an abnormality or not.
So that is a typical case where such a kind of a i model can be used which will keep on
considering the vibration pattern and the moments of abnormality is detected it will
raise an alarm.
So this is another example a i is extensively being used in healthcare in medical sciences.
a i being used in language translation think of our Indian scenario we have so many states
in every state we have a different language.
When I go to north I am comfortable I mean a bit comfortable with Hindi so I can communicate.
When I go to south I do not know anything of Tamil.
So I cannot communicate with those people.
So my medium of communication becomes English but if you go to remote villages in Tamil
narrow you do not you cannot expect them to know English so how do I communicate.
So there if I have a language translator which can language which can translate from English
to Tamil or say from Bengali to Tamil or Tamil to English Tamil to Bengali then our
life will be very easy.
So this is another domain where artificial intelligence or a i models can take a big role.
So the examples are many whatever you think of whatever you can do today's a i can do
the same thing.
So the domain where a i can perform is almost unlimited maybe sky is the limit.
What are other types of objects a i can discriminate other than images anything that you can measure
and quantify a i can work on that every a i model needs an input signal.
So anything that can be measured that gives a signal images I talked about that is just
a visual signal similarly there are audio signals which are acoustic signals so anything
that can be measured can be fed into a i model because a i model needs a signal.
Any other question? No. Thank you. Thank you very much.